mainz ist weil irgendwo ein pop up ist
ja auch mal so wenn er im internet und
legt es auf wegen so komischen
magazin.com direkt so popups und dann
bist du ganz woanders nein da will ich
nicht hin danke leute festgenommen als
willkommen beim neuen video und zwar
kann mehr von mir so vor zwei wochen
dieses video so beeindruckt man jeden
jung das war der zweite teil davon ich
habe mich gefragt ob ihr mal bock habt
auf so beeindruckt man auf jeden fall
kein jung weil also lachyoga wie man
halt so also als ich mir so gedanken
gemacht hab ich habe dabei ziemlich
viele dinge gefunden so im internet habe
mir sogar bei ernst young
dieses video so super euch angekommen
ist gibt es natürlich heute dann halt
auch dieses so beeindruckt man auf jeden
fall keinen jungen ich wünsche euch viel
spaß was noch intervention gefällt und
jetzt los und zwar ich habe natürlich
auch so ein bisschen im internet
recherchiert und mir ist der sonne seite
hält vor allem im fokus gefallen ich
will auch gar nicht nein sagen bravo
wird auch sonst muss sagen ein paar
dinge die dir da geschrieben haben waren
ganz okay kann man nachvollziehen hatte
ich auch ein zwei mit drin aber keinen
sinn dass irgendwer klich keinen sinn
und ist der größte scheiß ich mach das
einfach mal so ich lese jetzt halt ein
paar sachen vor die ich ziemlich
unpassend findet und dann halt so warum
mehr guckt einen schwarm an ob wenn er
nicht gerade nicht sieht er spürt sich
ja deinen blick auch auf größere
entfernung und wird sich gleich nach dir
umdrehen meinte dass da jetzt ernst sind
wir hier bei hier mania und was weis ich
bei super rtl was ich weiß es nicht auf
jeden fall habe ich mir dabei das können
jedoch nicht ernst war der heinz ehlers
geschrieben hat der autor hier oder was
man mit den ihr ich hab keine ahnung auf
jeden fall wenn ihr dem so hinterher tut
die ganze zeit sehen das vielleicht
andere und denken
seid ihr blöd oder ist die person blöd
was macht ihr da man blots die ganze
zeit den an ok ich belasse es hierüber
nächstes auch totaler bullshit arme sein
essen wenn er sich nach rechts liest du
dich eben so in die richtung stützt den
kopf auf die hände
machst du das auch dadurch ständig
unbewusst ein total sympathisch war ich
würde eher sagen dadurch nämlich nicht
unbewusst als total nervig war also ich
weiß es nicht ich stelle mir das so vor
euch sitzt also ein unterricht oder so
macht so ebenso ein mädchen noch
aussuchen
ich gehe so die gegend auch ich mache so
die macht auch so
dann würde ich mir denken was ist mit
dir falsch konzern tätig war liebe auf
den unterricht anstatt mir so komisch
nach zu affen oder so ich weiß es nicht
aber naja das nächste ist auch richtig
geil
darf ich mir richtig kaputt gelacht auf
jeden fall passt auf wenn du mit ihm
redest sprich ein
wenn du mit ihm redest sprich ein wenig
tiefer wenn dein schwarm in der nähe ist
es weg 6 die unsere hilfe alter
stell dir vor sondern mädchen so die
räte sowieso ein junger basti sexy und
regnet es wirkt einfach nur richtig
akteuren
hallo ich bin schon toll wie geht's dir
und dann wenn ich jetzt dran der junge
nicht automatisch höher weil das ist
auch dann wirkt sektion dreifach nächste
ist ja gut ich lese es einfach mal vor
du hast einen großen bruder fragezeichen
super schnapp dir sein rudi und ziehen
in die schule an die jungs werden denken
er ist von einem freund und das macht
dich total bgw etwas und das macht mich
total begehrenswert für sie also erst
muss ich sagen so ein mädchen im
pullover ist okay school habe ich auch
gesagt hin und wieder aber das macht
dich doch nicht begehrenswert dann
sondern eher das andere weil wenn die
denken du hast einen freund dann ist ja
eigentlich nicht so gut wenn du
irgendwie ganz gut findest nächste ist
auch super ich meine wir leben ja im
jahr 1984 oder so und zwar schicke ihm
per e mail verschickte e mails schicken
per mail ein filmplakat und schreibe
dazu 18 uhr kino kommt somit ich würde
sogar mein popcorn mit ihr teilen bei
einem so lockeren scharmann angebot kann
er gar nicht
weil diese ein filmplakat wäre das jetzt
so schicken eine web nachricht mit einem
zettel wo das drauf steht das ist was
anderes
aber du kannst sind doch keine e-mail
schicken stell dir vor e mails liest
doch kein junges stelle vaters ließ dann
die mutter oder so was hat die denn dann
für eine von ihr sonst ist das nötig
bahn zug wäre der sport auch okay aber
18 uhr macht lieber 20 uhr und kommst du
mit ist auch gut ich würde sogar mein
punkt von mit dir teilen ja das ist okay
das waren jetzt fünf sachen die so
überhaupt nicht verstanden habe ich habe
noch ganz viel mehr gefunden also wenn
ihr bock hab das davon frecher und
zweiter teil kommt dann lassen daumen
nach oben aber dass es mich in den
kommentaren wissen an sonst wäre ich
sagen ihnen setting und so war alles
schöner werden abo nie vergessen auch
nächste woche kehrte langsam um nichts
mehr zu verpassen
und hier auf der rechten seite oben geht
es weiter mit diesem video so
beeindruckt man jeden jung 26 ab und wir
sehen uns dann am nächsten montag wieder
auf